ZONE.
TRAVIS HAMONIC IN HIS THIRD GAME
BACK FOR VANCOUVER.
PLAYED IT TO THE TIPPED IT IN
TO MAKE IT 1-0.
>> John G: BOY, THE DUCKS
COULDN'T ASK FOR A BETTER START.
THEY H H GOAL
3 MINUTES 20 SECONDS IN
CLEARLY WELL INSIDE 3-0. STICK.
YOU SEE HE'S GOT HAVE ANOTHER PR
PLAY GOAL.
THEY'RE TWO FOR THREE
HENRIQUE HAS A COUPLE OF WHACKS
AT IT BEFORE HE GETS FOR
THATCHER DEMKO
AND WATCH DEMKO. BOARD.
>> John G: WELL, THIS ONE APPEAS
IT OFF.
>> JohnN THIS GAMES
A THE CANUCKS HAVE THEIR SECONDD
THE DUCKS LEAD 6-2.
>> John S:
LEFT PAD FLASHED OUT TO MAKE TH.
READ THE PLAY VERY WELL. SOME C.
YOU'RE DOWN 6-2, SO THE DEFENCE
PINCH IN,RIERS COMES IN, AND
HE'S THE LATE, LATE MAN.
AND HE'S WIDE OPENN
ANGLES WAS ABLE TO GET THAT
BACKHANDER TO GO AND MAKE IT
BAE
NET. FROM A DEFENCEMAN.
AND IT'S 7-4. MIDDLE AND JUST
LET'S IT